the following is a conversation with
kamran vaffa a theoretical physicist at
harvard
specializing in string theory he is the
winner
of the 2017 breakthrough prize in
fundamental physics
which is the most lucrative academic
prize in the world
quick mention of our sponsors headspace
jordan harmon just show
squarespace and all form check them out
in the description to support this
podcast
as a side note let me say that string
theory is a theory of quantum gravity
that unifies quantum mechanics
and general relativity it says that
quarks electrons and
all other particles are made up of much
tinier strings of vibrating energy
they vibrate in 10 or more dimensions
depending on the flavor of the theory
different vibrating patterns result in
different particles
from its origins for a long time string
theory was seen
as too good not to be true but has
recently fallen out of favor in the
physics community
partly because over the past 40 years it
has not been able to make any novel
predictions
that could then be validated through
experiment
nevertheless to this day it remains one
of our best candidates
for a theory of everything or a theory
that unifies the laws of physics
let me mention that a similar story
happened with neural networks in the
field of artificial intelligence
where it fell out of favor after decades
of promise and research
but found success again in the past
decade
as part of the deep learning revolution
so i think it pays to keep an open mind
since we don't know which of the ideas
in physics may be brought back
decades later and be found to solve the
biggest mysteries
in theoretical physics string theory
still
has that promise this is the lex
friedman podcast and here is my
conversation
with kamran vaffa what is the difference
between
mathematics and physics well that's a
difficult question because in many ways
math and physics
are unified in many ways so to
distinguish them
is not an easy task i would say that
perhaps the goals
are of math and physics are different uh
math does not care to describe reality
physics does that's the major difference
but a lot of the
thoughts processes and so on which goes
to understanding the nature and reality
are the same things that mathematicians
do so in many ways they are similar
mathematicians care about deductive
reasoning and physicists or physics in
general we care less
about that we care more about
interconnection of ideas
about how ideas support each other or if
there's a puzzle con
discord between ideas that's more
interesting for us
and part of the reason is that we have
learned in physics that the ideas are
not sequential
and if we think that there's one idea
which is more important and we start
with there and go to the next idea and
next one and deduce things from that
like mathematicians do
we have learned that the like the third
or fourth thing we deduce from that
principle turns out later on to be the
actual principle
and from a different perspective
starting from there leads to new ideas
which the original one didn't lead to
and that's the beginning of a new
revolution in science
so this kind of thing we have seen again
and again in the history of science we
have learned
to not like deductive reasoning because
that gives us a
bad starting point to think that we
actually have the original thought
process
should be viewed as the primary thought
and all these are deductions
like the way mathematicians sometimes
does so in physics we are learning to be
skeptical of that way of thinking we
have to be a bit open to the possibility
that what we thought is a deduction
of a hypothesis actually the reason
that's true
is the opposite and so we reverse the
order and so this
this switching back and forth between
ideas makes us
more fluid about a deductive fashion of
course
it sometimes gives a wrong impression
like physicists don't care about rigor
they just
you know they just say random things you
know they are willing to to say things
that are not backed by you know
the logical reasoning that's not true at
all so
despite despite this fluidity in saying
which one is a primary
thought we are very careful about trying
to understand what we have really
understood
in terms of relationship between ideas
so that's
that's the that's an important
ingredient and in fact
solid math being behind physics is i
think
uh one of the attractive features of a
of a physical law so we look for
beautiful math underpinning can we dig
into that process
of starting from one place and then the
uh ending up at like the fourth step and
realizing
all along that the place you started at
was wrong so
is that happen when there's a
discrepancy between
what the math says and what the physical
world shows
is that how you then can go back and do
the
revolutionary idea for different
starting place altogether
perhaps i'll give an example to see see
how it goes and in fact the historical
example
is newton's work on classical mechanics
so so newton formulated the laws of
mechanics
uh you know the force f equals to m a
and
his other laws and they look very simple
elegant and so forth
later when we studied more examples
of of mechanics and other similar things
physicists came up with the idea that
the notion of potential is interesting
potential was an abstract idea which
kind of came you could
take its gradient and relate it to the
force so you don't really need
it apiary but it solved helps some
thoughts
and then later euler and lagrange
reformulated newtonian mechanics in a
totally different way
in the following fashion they said if
you take if you want to know where
particle at this point and at this time
how does it get to this point at the
later time
is the following you take all possible
paths connecting this particle from
going from
the initial point to the final point and
you compute
the action on what is an action action
is the integral over time
of the kinetic term of the particle
minus its potential
so you take this integral and each path
will give you some quantity and
the path it actually takes the physical
path
is the one which minimizes this integral
or this action
now this sounded like a backwards step
from newton's newton's
form that seems very simple f equals to
m a and you can write f is minus the
gradient of the potential
so why would anybody start formatting
such a simple thing in terms of this
complicated
looking principle you have to study the
space of
all paths and all things and find the
minimum and then you get the same
equation so what's the point
so euler and lagrange's formulation of
newton which is a
which was kind of recasting in this
language
is just a consequence of newton's law f
equals m it gives you the same
fact that this path is a minimum action
now
what we learned later last century was
that
when we deal with quantum mechanics
newton's law is only
an average correct and
the particle going from one to the other
doesn't take
exactly one path it takes all the paths
yes with the with the amplitude which is
proportional to the exponential of the
action times an imaginary number
i and so this fact turned out to be the
reformulation of quantum mechanics we
should start there as the basis
of the new law which is quantum
mechanics and newton is only an
approximation on the average correct
when we say amplitude you mean
probability but yes the amplitude means
if you com sum up all these paths with
exponential i times the action
if you sum this up you get the number
complex number
you square the norm of this complex
number gives you a probability to go
from one to the other
is there ways in which mathematics can
lead us astray
when we use it as a tool to understand
the physical world
yes i would say that mathematics can
lead us astray as much as
all physical ideas can lead us so
sure if you get stuck in some something
then you can easily fool yourself that
just like
the thought process we have to free
ourselves of that sometimes math does
that rule like say oh this is such a
beautiful math i definitely want to use
it somewhere and so
you just get carried away and you just
get maybe carried too far away so that
is certainly true but i wouldn't say
it's more dangerous than all physical
ideas to me
new math ideas uh is as much potential
to lead us astray as all physical ideas
which could be
long-held principles of physics so i'm
just saying that we should keep an open
uh mind about the role the math plays
not to be antagonistic towards it
and not to over overwhelming it we
should just be open to possibilities
what about looking at a particular
characteristics of both physical ideas
and mathematical ideas which is beauty
you think beauty leads us astray meaning
um
and and you offline showed me a a really
nice puzzle that illustrates this
this idea a little bit now maybe you can
speak to that or another
example where uh beauty
makes it tempting for us to assume that
the the law and the theory
we found is actually one that perfectly
describes reality
i think that beauty does not lead us
astray
because i feel that beauty is a
requirement
for principles of physics so beauty is a
fundamental in the universe i think
beauty is fundamental
at least that's the way many of us view
it it's not emergent
it's not immersion i think i think hardy
is the mathematician who said that
there's no
permanent place for ugly mathematics and
so i think the same is true in physics
that if we find a principle which looks
ugly
we're not going to be that's not the end
stage so therefore beauty is going to
lead us somewhere now it doesn't mean
beauty is enough
it doesn't mean if you just have beauty
if i just look at something is beautiful
then i'm fine no that's not the case
beauty is certainly a criteria that
every
good physical theory should pass that's
at least the view we have
why do we have this view that's a good
question
it is a partly uh you could say based on
experi
experience of science over centuries
partly is
a philosophical view of what what what
reality is or should be
and uh in principle you know it could
have been ugly
and we might have had to deal with it
but we have gotten maybe
uh confident through examples after
examples in the history of science to
look for beauty
and our sense of beauty seems to
incorporate a lot of things that are
essential for us to solve some difficult
problems like symmetry we find symmetry
beautiful and the breaking of symmetry
beautiful
somehow symmetry is a is a fundamental
part of how we conceive of beauty
at all layers of reality which is
interesting like
uh in in both the visual space like when
we look at art
we look at each other as human beings
the way we look at creatures in the
biological space
the way we look at chemistry and then
into the physics world as
as the work you do it's kind of
interesting it makes you wonder like
which one is the chicken or the egg is
symmetry the the chicken and our
conception of beauty the egg
or the other way around or somehow
the fact that every the symmetry is is
part of reality
is it somehow creates the brain that
then is able to perceive it
or maybe that's this is just because we
maybe it's so obvious
it's almost trivial that symmetry of
course will be part of every kind of
universe that's possible
uh and then our any kind of organism
that's able to observe that universe is
going to appreciate
uh symmetry well these are good
questions we don't have a deeper
understanding of why we get attracted to
symmetry
why do laws of nature seem to have
symmetries
underlying them and the reasoning or the
examples of whether
if it wasn't symmetric we would have
understood it or not we could have said
that yeah if there were
you know things which didn't look that
great we could understand them for
example we know
that symmetries get broken and we have
appreciated nature
in the broken symmetry phase as well the
word we live in
has many things which do not look
symmetric but even those
have underlying symmetry when you look
at it more deeply so
we have gotten maybe spoiled perhaps by
by the appearance of symmetry all over
the place
and we look for it and i think this is
this is perhaps related to the sense of
aesthetics that scientists have
and we don't usually talk about it among
scientists
in fact it's kind of a philosophical
view of
why do we look for simplicity or beauty
or so forth
and uh i think in a sense scientists are
ma
a lot like philosophers sometimes i
think especially modern science seems to
shine away
sean's philosophers and philosophical
views and i think
at their peril i think i think in my
view science
owes a lot to philosophy and
in my view many scientists in fact
probably all good scientists are
perhaps amateur philosophers they may
not state that they are philosophers or
they they may not
like to be labeled philosophers but in
many ways what they do is like what
is philosophical takes of things
looking for simplicity or symmetry is an
example of that in my opinion
or seeing patterns you see for example
another example of the
symmetry is like how you come up with
new ideas in science you see for example
an
idea a is connected with an idea b
okay so you you study this connection
very deeply
and then you find the cousin of an idea
a let me call it a prime
and then you immediately look for b
prime if a
is like b and if there's an a prime then
you look for b prime why well
it completes the picture why well it's
philosophically appealing to have more
balance in terms of that
and then you look for b prime and behold
you find this other phenomena which is a
physical phenomenon which you call b
prime so this kind of thinking motivates
asking questions and looking for things
and it has guided scientists i think
through many centuries and i think it
continues to do so today
and i think if you look at the long arc
of history i suspect that the things
that will be remembered
is the philosophical flavor of the ideas
of physics and chemistry and computer
science and mathematics
like i think the actual details
will be shown to be incomplete or maybe
wrong
but the philosophical intuitions will
carry through much longer
there's a sense in which if it's true
that we haven't figured out
most of how things work currently
that uh it'll all be shown as wrong and
silly it'd
almost be a historical artifact but the
the human spirit whatever like the the
longing to understand
the the way we perceive the world the
way we conceive of it
of our place in the world those those
ideas will carry on
i completely agree in fact i believe
that uh almost
well i believe that none of the
principles or laws of physics we know
today are exactly correct
all of them are approximations to
something they are better than the
previous versions that we had but
none of them are exactly correct and
none of them are going to stand forever
so i agree that that's the process we
are heading we are improving
and yes indeed the thought process and
that philosophical take
is common so when we look at you know
older uh
scientists or maybe even all the way
back to greek philosophers and the
things that the way they thought and so
on
almost everything they said about you
know nature was incorrect
but the way they thought about it and
many things that they were thinking
is still valid today for example they
thought about symmetry breaking
they were trying to explain the
following they were this is a beautiful
example i think they had figured out
that the earth is round
and they said okay earth is around they
have you know they have seen the
length of the shadow of this meter stick
and they have seen that if you go from
the equator upwards north
they find that depending on how far away
you are the length of the shadow changes
and from that they have either they had
even measured the radius of the earth
to good accuracy that's brilliant by the
way the fact that they did that
very brilliant very brilliant so these
greek philosophers were very smart and
so
they had taken it to the next step they
asked okay so the earth is round
why doesn't it move they thought it
doesn't move they they were looking
around nothing seemed to move so
so they said okay we have to have a good
explanation it wasn't enough for them to
you know be there so they really want to
deeply understand that fact and they
come up with a symmetry argument
and the symmetry argument was oh if the
earth
is a spherical it must be at the center
of the universe for sure so they said
the earth is at the center of the
universe it makes sense
and they said you know if the earth is
going to move which direction does it
pick
any direction it picks it breaks that
spherical symmetry because you have to
pick a direction
and that's not good because it's not
symmetrical anymore so therefore
the earth decides to sit put because it
would break the symmetry so
so they had the incorrect science they
thought earth doesn't move and they but
they had this beautiful idea that
symmetry might explain it
but they were even smarter than that
aristotle didn't agree with this
argument
he said why do you think symmetry
prevents it from moving because the
preferred position
not so he gave an example he said
suppose
you are a person and you put we put you
at the center of a circle
and we spread food around you on a
circle around you
loaves of bread let's say and we say
okay
stay at the center of the circle forever
are you going to do that just because of
the symmetric point
no you're going to get hungry you're
going to move towards one of those
levels of bread
despite the fact that it breaks the
symmetry so from this way he tried to
argue
being at this symmetric point may not be
the preferred thing to do
and this idea of spontaneous mystery
breaking is something we just
used today to describe many physical
phenomena so spontaneous symmetry
breaking
is the feature that we now use but this
idea was there
thousands of years ago but applied
incorrectly to the physical world but
now we are using it so these ideas are
coming back in different forms
so i agree very much that the thought
process is more important and these
ideas are more interesting than the
actual applications that
people may find today did they use the
language of symmetry and the symmetry
breaking and spontaneous symmetry that's
really interesting yes
because like i could see a conception of
the universe that kind of tends towards
perfect symmetry and is stuck there like
they
not stuck there but achieves that
optimal and stays there
the idea that you would spontaneously
break out of symmetry
like have these perturbations like jump
out of symmetry
and back that's not that's a really
difficult idea to uh
to load into your head like where where
does that come from
and then and then the idea that you may
not be at the center of the universe
right that is a really tough idea right
so symmetry sometimes is an explanation
of being at the symmetric point is
sometimes a simple explanation of many
things like
if you have a bowl a
circular ball then the bottom of it is
the lowest point so if you put a you
know pebble or something it will slide
down and go there at the bottom and
stays there
at the symmetric point because the
preferred point the lowest energy point
but if that same symmetric circular ball
that you had had a
bump on the on the bottom the bottom
might not be at the center
it might be on a circle on the table
yeah in which case the pebble would not
end up at the center would be the lower
energy point
symmetrical but it breaks the symmetry
once it picks a point on that circle
so so we can't have symmetry reasoning
for where things end up
or symmetry breakings like this example
would suggest
we talked about beauty i find geometry
to be beautiful
uh you have uh a few examples
that are geometric in nature in your
book
how can geometry in ancient times or
today be used to understand
reality and maybe how do you think about
geometry as a distinct tool
in mathematics and physics yes geometry
is my favorite part of math as well and
greeks were enamored by geometry they
tried to describe
physical reality using geometry and
principles of geometry and symmetry
platonic solids the five solids they had
discovered had these beautiful solids
they thought it must be good for some
reality there must be explaining
something they attached you know
one to air one to fire and so forth they
try to give
physical reality to symmetric objects
these symmetric objects are symmetries
of rotation
and discrete symmetry groups we call
today of rotation group in three
dimensions
now we know now we kind of laugh at the
way they were trying to connect that
symmetry to you know the laws of the the
realities of
of physics but actually it turns out
in modern days we use symmetries in not
too far away
exactly in these kind of thoughts
processes in the following way
in the co in the context of string
theory which is this
the field i study we have these extra
dimensions
and these extra dimensions are compact
tiny spaces typically but they have
different shapes and sizes
we have learned that if you if these
extra shapes and sizes have symmetries
which are related to the same rotation
symmetries that the greek we're talking
about
if they enjoy those discrete symmetries
and if you
if you take that symmetry and quotient
the space by that in other words
identify points under these symmetries
you get properties of that space at the
singular points
which force emanates from them what
forces
forces like the ones we have seen in
nature today like electric forces
like strong forces like weak forces so
these same principles
that was were driving them to connect
geometry and symmetries
to nature is driving today's
physics now much more you know modern
ideas but nevertheless the symmetries
connecting
geometry to physics in fact often we
sometimes we have we ask the following
questions suppose i want to get this
particular
you know physical reality i want to have
this particles with these forces and so
on what do i do
it turns out that you can geometrically
design the space
to give you that you say oh i put the
sphere here i would do this i will
shrink them
so if you have two spheres touching each
other and shrinking through
to zero size that gives you strong
forces
if you have one of them it gives you the
weak forces if you have this you get
that and if you want to unify forces do
the other thing
so these geometrical translation of
physics is one of my favorite things
that we have discovered in modern
physics in the context of strength
theory
the sad thing is when you go into
multiple dimensions and
we'll talk about it is we start to lose
our
capacity to uh visually intuit
the world we're discussing and then we
go into the realm of mathematics and
we'll lose that
unfortunately our brains are such that
we're limited but
before we go into that mysterious
beautiful world
let's take a small step back and you
also in your book have this
kind of through the space of puzzles
through the space of ideas have a
brief history of physics
of physical ideas now we we talked about
newtonian mechanics
uh leading all through different
lagrangian hamiltonian mechanics
can you describe some of the key ideas
in the history of physics
maybe lingering on each from
electromagnetism to relativity to
quantum mechanics and to today as we'll
talk about with quantum gravity and
strength theory sure so um i mentioned
the classical mechanics and the euler
lagrangian formulation
one of the next important milestones for
physics were the discoveries of laws of
their christian magnetism
so maxwell put put the discoveries all
together in the context of what we call
the maxwell's equations
and he noticed that when he put these
discoveries that you know faradays and
others had made
about electric and magnetic phenomena
the in terms of mathematical equations
it didn't quite work
there was a mathematical inconsistency
now
uh you know one could have had two
attitudes won't say okay who cares about
math i'm doing nature you know electric
force magnetic force
math i don't care about but it bothered
him it was inconsistent the equations
you were writing the two equations he
had written down did not agree with each
other
and this bothered him but he figured out
you know if you add this jiggle this
equation by adding one little term there
it works
at least it's consistent what is the
motivation for that term
he said i don't know have we seen it in
experiments no
why did you add it well because of
mathematical consistency so he said
okay math forced him to
do this term he added this term which we
now today call the maxwell term
and once he added that term his
equations were nice you know
differential equations mathematically
consistent beautiful
but he also found the new physical
phenomena he found that because of that
term
he could now get electric and magnetic
waves
moving through space
at a speed that he could calculate so he
calculated the speed of the wave
and low and behold he found it's the
same as the speed of light
which puzzled him because he didn't
think light had anything to do with
electricity and magnetism
but then he was courageous enough to say
well maybe light is nothing but these
electric and magnetic fields moving
around
and he didn't he wasn't alive to see the
verification of that prediction and
indeed was true so this mathematical
inconsistency which which we could say
you know this mathematical
beauty drove him to this physical
very important connection between light
and electric magnetic phenomena which
was later confirmed
so then physics progresses and it comes
to einstein
einstein looks at maxwell's equation
this is beautiful these are a nice
equation except
we get one speed light who measures this
light
speed and he asks the question are you
are you moving are you not moving if you
move the speed of light changes but
maxwell's equation has no hint of
different speeds of light it doesn't say
oh
only if you're not moving you get the
speed it's just you always get this
speed so
einstein was very puzzled and he he was
daring enough to say well you know maybe
everybody gets the same speed for light
yeah and that motivated his theory of
special relativity
and this is an interesting example
because the idea was motivated from
physics from
maxwell's equations from the fact that
people tried to
try to measure the properties of ether
which was supposed to be the medium in
which the light travels through
and the idea was that only in that in
that medium the speed the speed of
if you're at rest with respect to the
ether this speed the speed of light then
if you're moving the speed changes
and people did not discover it
michaelson and morley's experiments
showed there is no ether
so uh then einstein was courageous
enough to say you know light is
the same speed for everybody regardless
of whether you're moving or not
and the interesting thing is about
special theory of relativity is that
the under the math underpinning it is
very simple
it's linear algebra nothing terribly
deep
you can teach it at a high school level
if not earlier
okay is does that mean einstein's
especially relativity is boring
not at all so this is an example where
simple math
you know linear algebra leads to deep
physics
einstein's theory of special relativity
motivated by this inconsistency at
maxwell
equation would suggest for the speed of
light depending on who observes it
what's the most daring idea there that
that the the speed of light could be the
same everywhere that's the basic that's
the guts of it that's the core of
einstein's theory that statement
underlies the whole thing speed of light
is the same for everybody is hard to
swallow
and it doesn't sound right it sounds
completely wrong on the face of it
and it was it took einstein to make to
make this the daring statement
it would be it would be laughing in some
sense how could possibly how could
anybody make this
possibly ridiculous claim and it turned
out to be true how does that make you
feel because it
it still sounds ridiculous it sounds
ridiculous until you learn that
our intuition is at fault about the way
we conceive of space on time
the way we think about space on time is
wrong because we think about the nature
of time as absolute
and part of it is because we live in a
situation where we don't go with very
high speeds that our speeds are small
compared to the speed of light
and therefore the phenomena we we
observe does not distinguish the
relativity of time
the time also depends on who measures
that there's no absolute time
when you say it's noon today now it
depends on who's measuring it and it
not everybody would agree with that
statement and to see that
you will have to have fast observer
moving you know
speeds close to speed of light so so
this shows that our intuition is at
fault
and a lot of the discoveries in physics
precisely is getting rid of the wrong
old intuition
and it is funny because we get rid of it
but it always lingers in us in some form
like
even when i'm describing it i feel like
a little bit like isn't it you know
funny
as you're just feeling the same way it
is yes it is but we kind of
replace it by an intuition
and actually there's a very beautiful
example of this how physicist do this
try to replace their intuition and i
think this is one of my favorite
examples about how physicists
develop intuition it goes to the work of
galileo
so you know again uh let's go back to
greek philosophers or maybe aristotle in
this case
now again let's let's make a criticism
he thought that objects
the heavier objects fall faster than the
lighter objects makes sense
it kind of makes sense and you know
people say about feather and swan but
that's because of the air resistant but
you might think like if you have a heavy
stone and a light pebble the heavy one
will fall first if you don't
you know do any experiments that's the
first gut reaction i would say everybody
would say that's the natural thing
galileo did not believe this and he kind
of
did the experiment famously it said he
went on the top of piso tower and he
dropped you know these heavy and light
stones and they fell at the same time
when they he dropped it at the same time
from the same height okay good so he
said i'm done you know i've showed that
the
heavy and lighter objects fought the
same time i did the experiment
scientists at that time did not accept
it
why was that because at that time
science was not just
experimental the experiment was not
enough
they didn't think that they have to sort
their hands in doing experiments to get
to the reality they said why is it the
case
why so galileo had to come up with an
explanation of why heavier and lighter
objects fought the same ray
this is the way he convinced them using
symmetry
he said suppose you have three bricks
the same
shape the same size
same as everything and we hold these
three bricks at the same height
and drop them which one will fall to the
ground
first everybody said of course we know
that symmetry
tells you know they're all the same
shape same size same height
of course they fall at the same time
yeah we know that next next
it's trivial he says okay what if we
move these bricks around with the same
height does it change the time they hit
the ground
they said if it's the same height again
by the symmetry principle because the
height translation horizontal
translation the symmetry
no it doesn't matter they all fall the
same rate good doesn't matter how close
i bring them together no it doesn't
okay suppose i make the two bricks touch
and then let them go do they fall out
the same raid
yes they do but they said well the two
bricks that touch
are twice more mass than this other
brick and you just agreed that they
fought the same rate
they say yeah yeah we just agreed that's
right that's strange yes
so he deconfused them by the symmetry
design so this way
of repackaging some intuition a
different intuition
when the intuitions clash then you then
you decide on the you replace the
intuition
that's brilliant i i in some of these
dif
more difficult physical ideas
physics ideas in the 20th century in the
21st century it starts becoming more and
more difficult
than replace the intuition you know what
does the world look like for an object
traveling close to the speed of light
you start to think about like the edges
of supermassive black holes
and you start to think like what what's
that look like
or uh i've been re into gravitational
waves recently
it's like when the fabric of space-time
is being morphed
by gravity like what's that actually
feel like
if i'm writing a gravitational wave
what's that feel like
i mean i think some of those are more
sort of hippie
not useful uh intuitions to have
but if you're an actual physicist or
whatever the particular discipline is i
wonder if it's possible to meditate
to sort of uh escape through thinking
prolonged thinking and meditation on a
war
on a world like live in a visualized
world that's not like our own
in order to understand a phenomenon
deeply so like replace the intuition
like through rigorous meditation on the
idea
in order to conceive of it i mean if we
talk about multiple dimensions
i wonder if there's a way to escape with
the three-dimensional world
in our mind in order to then start to
reason about it
it's uh the more i talk to topologists
the more they seem to not operate at all
at all in the visual space
they really trust the mathematics like
which is really annoying to me because
topology
and differential geometry feels like it
has a lot of potential for beautiful
pictures
yes i think they do actually i would not
be able to
uh do my my research if i don't have an
intuitive feel about geometry
and i i will get to it as you mentioned
late uh before that
how for example in strength there you
deal with these extra dimensions and
i'll be very happy
to describe how we do it because with
that intuition we will not get anywhere
and i
i don't think you can just rely on
formalism i don't
i don't think any physicist just relies
on formalism that's not physics that's
not understanding
so we have to intuit it and that's
crucial and this there are steps of
doing it and we learned it might not be
trivial
but we learned how to do it similar to
this galileo picture i just told you
you have to build these gradually but
about to connect the bricks
literally yeah so yeah so then uh so
going back to your question about this
the path of the history of the science
so i was
saying about the existing magnesium and
the special relativity where simple idea
led to special relativity but then he
went further
thinking about acceleration in the
context of relativity and he came up
with general relativity
where he talked about you know the
fabric of space time being curved and so
forth and
matter affecting the the curvature of
the space on time so
so this gradually became a
connection between geometry and physics
namely he replaced newton's
you know gravitational force with
a very geometrical beautiful picture
it's much more elegant than newton's but
much more complicated mathematically
so so when we say it's simpler we mean
in some form it's simpler but not in
pragmatic terms of equation solving the
equations are
much harder to solve in einstein's
theory and in fact so much
so much harder that einstein himself
couldn't solve many of his many of the
cases he thought for example you
couldn't solve the equation for a
spherical symmetric matter uh like like
if you had this symmetric sun
he didn't think you can actually write
this solve his equation for that and
a year after he he said that it was
solved by by short child so it was
it was that hard that he didn't think
it's going to be that easy so yeah the
formalism is hard
but the contrast between the special
relativity and general relativity is
very interesting because one of them has
almost trivial math
and the other one has super complicated
math
both are physically amazingly important
and so so we have learned that you know
the physics
may or may not require complicated math
we should not shy from using complicated
math like einstein did
nobody einstein wouldn't say i'm not
going to touch this math because it's
too much you know
tensors or you know curvature and i
don't like four-dimensional space-time
because i can't see four-dimension
he wasn't doing that he was willing to
abstract from that because
physics drove him in that direction but
his motivation was physics physics
pushed him
just like newton pushed to develop
calculus because physics pushed him that
he didn't have the tools so he had to
develop the tools
to answer his physics questions so his
motivation was physics again
so to me those are examples which showed
that math and physics have this
symbiotic reality relationship which
which kind of reinforce each other here
i'm using i'm giving you examples
of both of them namely newton's work led
to development of mathematics
calculus and in the case of einstein he
didn't develop
the premium geometry just use them so so
it goes both ways
and in the context of modern physics we
see that again and again it goes both
ways
let me ask a ridiculous question you
know you talk about your favorite soccer
player at a bar
i'll ask the same question about
einstein's ideas which is
uh which one do you think is the biggest
leap of genius
is it the uh e equals mc squared
is the brownian motion is it special
relativity is the general relativity
which which of of the famous set of
papers he's written in
1905 and in general his work was the
biggest leap of genius
in my opinion special relativity the
idea that speed of light is the same
for everybody is the beginning of
everything he did at the beginning is
this the beginning it's just once you
embrace
that weirdness the all the weirdness i
would say that's
that's it even though he says the most
beautiful moment for him yes he says
that is when he realized that if you
fall in an elevator you don't know if
you're falling or whether you're
in the whether you're in the falling
elevator or whether you're next to the
earth gravitational field
that that to him was his aha moment
which inertial mass and gravitational
mass being identical
geometrically and so forth as part of
the theory not because of
uh you know some some funny coincidence
uh that's for him but i feel from
outside at least it feels like
the speed of light being the same is the
is the really
aha moment the general relativity to you
is not
like the conception of space time in a
sense the conception of space time
already was
part of the speciality when you talk
about length contraction
so general relativity takes that to the
next step but beginning of it was
already
space link contracts time dilays so once
you talk about those then yeah you can
dilate more or less different places
than it's curvature
so you don't have a choice so it's kind
of started just with that same simple
thought
speed of light is the same for all where
does uh
quantum mechanics come into view exactly
so this is the next step so einstein's
you know
uh develops general activity and is
beginning to develop the foundation of
quantum mechanics at the same time the
photoelectric effects on others
and um so so quantum mechanics overtakes
in fact einstein in many ways because he
doesn't like the
probabilistic interpretation of quantum
mechanics and the formulas that's
emerging
but physicists march on and try to for
example
combine einstein's theory of relativity
with quantum mechanics so dirac takes
special relativity
tries to see how is it compatible with
quantum mechanics
can we pause and briefly say what is
quantum mechanics oh yes sure so quantum
mechanics
so i i discussed briefly when i talked
about the connection between newtonian
mechanics
and the euler lagrangian formulation of
of the newtonian mechanics and
interpretation of this
audio dot grunge formalism in terms of
the paths that the particle take
so when we say a particle goes from here
to here
we usually think it classically it
follows a specific trajectory
but actually in quantum mechanics it
falls
follows every trajectory with different
probabilities
and so there's this fuzziness now
most probable it's the path that you
actually see
and the deviation from that is very very
unlikely and probabilistically very
minuscule
so in everyday experiments we don't see
anything deviated from what we expect
but quantum mechanics tells us that the
things are more fuzzy things are
are not as precise as the line you draw
things are a bit like cloud so if you go
to microscopic
uh scales like atomic scales and lower
these phenomena become more pronounced
you can see it much better the electron
is is not at the point but
the clouds spread out around the nucleus
and so this fuzziness this probabilistic
aspect
of reality is what quantum mechanics
describes can i briefly pause on that on
that idea
do you think this is quantum mechanics
is just a really damn good approximation
a tool for predicting reality or does it
actually describe reality
do you think reality is fuzzy at that
level well i think that
reality is fuzzy at that level but i
don't think quantum mechanics is
necessarily the end of the story
right so um so quantum mechanics is
certainly an improvement over classical
physics that much we know by experiments
and so forth
whether i'm happy with quantum mechanics
whether i view quantum mechanics
for example the the thought the
measurement uh
description of quantum mechanics am i
happy with it am i thinking that's the
end stage or not
i don't i don't think we're at the end
of that story and many physicists
may or may not view this way some do
some don't
but i think that it's the best we have
right now that's for sure
it's the best approximation for reality
we know today and so far we don't know
what it is the next thing that
improves it or replaces it and so on so
but as i mentioned before i don't
believe
any of the laws of physics we know today
are friends
that's exactly correct it doesn't bother
me yes i'm not like dogmatic say i have
figured out this is the law of nature
i know everything no no that's that's
the the beauty about science is that we
are not dogmatic
and we are we are willing to in fact we
are encouraged to
be skeptical of what we ourselves do so
you were talking about dirac
yes i was talking about direct right so
direct was trying to now combine this
schrodinger's equations which which was
described in the context of you know
trying to
talk about how these probabilistic waves
of electrons move
for the atom which was good for for
speeds which were not too close to the
speed of light
to what happens when you get to the near
the speed of light
so then you need relativity so then
dirac tried to combine einstein's
relativity with quantum mechanics
so he tried to combine them and he wrote
this beautiful equation
the dirac equation which roughly
speaking take the square root of of the
einstein's equation in order to connect
it to schrodinger's time evolution
operator which is
first order in time derivative to get
rid of the
the naive thing that einstein's equation
would have given which is second order
so you have to take a square root
now square root usually has a plus or
minus sign when you take it
and when he did this he originally
didn't notice this
didn't pay attention to this plus or
minus sign but later physics pointed out
to direct says look there's also this
minus sign and if you use this minus
sign you get negative energy
in fact it was very very annoying that
you know somebody else tells you this
obvious mistake you make paulie
famous physicist told direct this is
nonsense you're going to get negative
energy with your equation with negative
energy without any bottom you can go all
the way down to negative
infinite energy so it doesn't make any
sense direct thought about it and then
he remembered paulie's exclusion
principle before just before him paulie
had said you know
there's this principle called the
exclusion principle that you know two or
two electrons cannot be on the same
orbit
and so direct said okay you know what
all these negative energy states
are filled orbits occupied
so according to you uh
mr paulie there's no place to go so
therefore they only have to go positive
sounded like a big cheat and then paulie
said oh you know what
we can change orbits from one orbit to
another what if i take one of these
negative energy orbits and put it up
there
then it seems to be a new particle which
has opposite
properties to the electron has positive
energy but it has positive charge
what is that like
the iraq was a bit worried he said maybe
that's proton because proton has plus
charge he wasn't sure but then he said
oh maybe it's proton
but then they said no no no it has the
same mass as the electron cannot be
proton because proton is heavier
the iraq was stuck he says well then
maybe another part we haven't seen
by that time dirac himself was getting a
little bit
worried about his own equation and his
own crazy interpretation
yes until a few years later anderson in
photographic cosmic uh
in the photographic place that he had
gotten from this cosmic rays
he discovered a particle which goes in
the opposite direction that the electron
goes when there's a magnetic field
and with the same mass exactly like what
the iraq had predicted
and this was what we call now positron
and in fact
beginning with the work of dirac we know
that every particle has an anti-particle
and so this idea that there's an
anti-particle came from the simple math
you know there's a plus and a minus
from the directs quote-unquote mistake
so again trying to combine ideas
sometimes the math is smarter than the
person who uses it to
apply it and you try to resist it and
then you you kind of confront it by
criticism which is the way it should be
so physicist comes and said no no that's
wrong and you correct it and so on so
that
is the development of the idea there's
particle there's antiparticle and so on
so this is the beginning of
development of quantum mechanics and the
connection with relativity but the thing
was more challenging because
we had to also describe how electric and
magnetic fields
work with quantum mechanics this was
much more complicated because it's not
just one point
electric and magnetic fields were
everywhere so you had to talk about
fluctuating and a fuzziness of
electrical field and magnetic fields
everywhere
and the math for that was was was very
difficult to deal with
and this led to a subject called quantum
field theory fields
like electric and magnetic field to be
quantum had to be described
also in a wavy way feinman in particular
was one of the pioneers along with
schwinger's and others
to try to come up with the formalism to
deal with fields
like electric and magnetic fields
interacting with electrons
in a consistent quantum fashion and they
just developed this beautiful theory
quantum electrodynamics from that and
later on that same formalism quantum
field theory led to the
discovery of other forces and other
particles all consistent with the idea
of quantum
mechanics so that was how physics
progressed
and so basically we learned that all
particles and all the forces
are are in some sense related to
particle exchanges
and so for example electromagnetic
forces are
are mediated by a particle we call
photon and
uh and so forth and the same for other
forces that they discovered strong
forces and the weak forces so
so we got the sense of what quantum
field theory is is that a big leap
of uh of an idea that uh
particles are fluctuations in the field
like the idea that everything is a field
is the old einstein
light is a wave both a particle and a
wave kind of idea is that is that a huge
leap in our understanding of conceiving
the universe's fields
i would say so i would say that on
viewing the particles
this duality that bore mentioned between
particles and waves that waves can
behave sometimes like particles
sometimes like waves
is one of the biggest leaps of
imagination
that quantum mechanics made physics do
so i agree that that is
quite remarkable is duality fundamental
to
to the universe or is it just because we
don't understand it fully like we'll
eventually collapse into a clean
explanation that doesn't require duality
like
th that that a phenomenon could be two
things at once and both
to be true so that seems weird so in
fact i
i i was going to get to that when we get
to string theory but maybe i can comment
on that now
duality turns out to be running the show
today is the whole thing
that we are doing in strength duality is
the name of the game
so it's the most beautiful subject i
want to talk about let's let's talk
about it in the context
let's talk about the other strengths so
we uh do want to take a next step into
because we mentioned general relativity
we mentioned quantum mechanics
is there something to be said about
quantum gravity yes that's exactly the
right point to talk about
so namely we have talked about quantum
fields and i talked about electric
forces
photon being the particle carrying those
forces so for gravity
quantizing gravitational field which is
this curvature of space time according
to einstein
you get another particle called graviton
so what about gravitons should be there
no problem so then you start computing
it
what do i mean by computing it well you
compute scattering of one graviton off
another graviton maybe with graviton
with an electron and so on see what you
get
feynman had already mastered the this
quantum electrodynamics you said no
problem let me do it
even though these are such weak forces
the gravity is very weak so therefore to
see them
these quantum effects of gravitational
waves is was impossible
it's even impossible today so feynman
just did it for fun
he usually you know had this mindset
that i want to do something which i will
see an experiment but this one let's
just see what it does
and he was surprised because the same
techniques he was using for doing
the same calculations quantum
electrodynamics when applied to gravity
failed the formula seemed to make sense
but he had to do some integrals and he
found that when he does those integrals
he got infinity
and it didn't make any sense now there
are similar infinities in the other
pieces that but he had managed to make
sense out of those before
this was no way he could make sense out
of it he just didn't know what to do
he didn't feel as an urgent issue
because nobody could do the experiment
so he was kind of said okay there's this
thing but okay we don't know how to
exactly do it but
but that's the way it is so in some
sense a natural conclusion
from what feynman did could have been
like gravity cannot be consistent with
quantum theory
but that cannot be the case because
gravity is in our universe quantum
mechanics is our universe they both
together somehow it should work
so it's not acceptable to say you know
they don't work together so
so that was a puzzle how does it
possibly work it was
left open and then we get to the string
theory so this is the puzzle of quantum
gravity the particle description of
quantum gravity fails
so the infinity shows up what do we do
what do we do with infinity
let's get to the fun part let's talk
about string theory yes
uh let's uh discuss some
technical basics of uh string theory
what is string theory
what is the string how many dimensions
are we talking about
what are the different states how do we
represent the elementary particles
and the laws of physics using this
new framework so string theory
is the idea that the fundamental
entities are not
particles but extended higher
dimensional objects like one-dimensional
strings
like loops these loops could be open
like
with two ends like an interval or a
circle
without any ends so and they're
vibrating and moving around in space
so how big they are well you can of
course stretch it and make it big
or you can just let it be whatever it
wants it can be as small as a point
because the
circle can shrink to a point and be very
light
or you can you know stretch it and
becomes very massive or it could
oscillate and become massive that way so
depends on
which kind of state you have in fact
this string can have infinitely many
modes depending on which kind of
oscillation it's doing like a guitar
has different harmonics string has
different harmonics but for the string
each harmonic is a particle
so each particle will give you ah this
is a more massive harmonic this is a
less mass
so the lightest harmonic so to speak is
no harmonics which means like
a string strung to a point and then it
becomes like a
massless particles or light particles
like photon
and graviton and so forth so when when
you look at
tiny strings which are strong to a point
the lightest ones
they look like the particles that we we
think they're like particles in other
words
from far away they look like a point but
of course if you zoom in there's this
tiny little you know little circle
that's there
that's strong to almost a point should
we be imagining
this is to the visual intuition should
we be imagining
literally strings that are potentially
connected as a loop
or not when you and when somebody
outside of physics
is imagining a basic element of string
theory which is a string
should we literally be thinking about a
string yes you should literally think
about string
but string with zero thickness with zero
thickness
so notice it's a it's a it's a loop of
energy so to speak
if you can think of it that way and so
there's a tension like the regular
string if you pull it there's you know
you have to you have to stretch it
but it's not like a thickness like
you're made of something it's just
energy
it's not made of atoms or something like
that but and it is very very tiny
much smaller than uh elementary
particles of physics
much smaller so we think if you let the
string to be
by itself the lowest state they'll be
like a fuzziness or a size of that tiny
little circle which is like a point
about could be anything between we don't
know the exact size but
in different models have different sizes
but something of the order of 10 to the
minus
let's say 30 centimeters so
10 to the minus 30 centimeters just to
compare with the size of the atom which
is 10 to the minus
8 centimeters is 22 orders of magnitude
smaller
so so unimaginably small very small so
we basically think from far away string
is like a point particle
and that's why a lot of the things that
we learned about point particle physics
carries over directly to strings
so therefore there's not not much of a
mystery why particle physics was
successful because string is like a
particle when it's not stretched
but it turns out having this size being
able to oscillate
get bigger turned out to be resolving
these puzzles
that feynman was having in calculating
his diagrams
and it gets rid of those infinities so
when you're trying to do those
infinities the regions that give
infinities to feynman
as soon as you get to those regions then
this string starts to oscillate and
these oscillation structure of the
strings
resolves those infinities to finite
answer at the end so
the size of the string the fact is one
dimensional gives a finite answer at the
end
resolves this paradox now
perhaps it's also useful to recount of
how string theory came to be
yes because it wasn't like somebody said
well let me
solve the problem of einstein's solve
the problem that feynman had with
unifying einstein stated with quantum
mechanics by replacing the point by a
string no
that's not the way the thought process
the thought process was
much more random physicist
veneziano in this case was trying to
describe the interactions they were
seeing in
colliders in in accelerators
and they were seeing that some process
in some process when two particles came
together
and joined together and went they were
separately
in one way and the opposite way they
behaved the same way
in some way there was a symmetry a
duality
which she didn't understand the
particles didn't seem to have that
symmetry
he said i don't know what it is what's
the reason that these colliders and
experiments we're doing seems to have
the symmetry but let me write a
mathematical formula
which exhibits that symmetry he used
gamma functions beta functions and all
that you know complete
math no physics other than trying to get
symmetry out of his equation
he just wrote down a formula as the
answer for a process
not not a method to compute it just say
wouldn't it be nice if this was the
answer
yes this is looked at this one that's
intriguing it has the symmetry
all right but what is this where is this
coming from which which kind of physics
gives you this
so i don't know yeah a few years later
people saw that oh the equation that
you're right is the process you're
writing in the intermediate channels
that particles come together
seems to have all the harmonics harmonic
sounds like a string
let me see if what you're describing has
anything with the strings and people try
to see if
what he's doing has anything with the
strings oh yeah indeed
if i study scattering of two strings i
get exactly the formula you wrote down
that was the reinterpretation of what he
had written in the formula
as a string but still had nothing to do
with gravity
it had nothing to do with resolving the
problems of gravity with quantum
mechanics
it was just trying to explain a process
that people were seeing in hydronic
physics collisions
so it took a few a few more years to get
to that point
they did notice that physics notice
that whenever you try to find the
spectrum of strings you always get a
massive particle
which has exactly the properties that
the graviton is supposed to have
and no particle in hydronic physics that
had that property
you are getting a massless graviton as
part of this scattering without
looking for it it was forced on you
people were not trying to solve quantum
gravity quantum gravity was pushed on
them
i don't want this graviton get rid of it
they couldn't get rid of it they gave up
trying to get rid of it physicists said
shark and shorts said you know what
strength is theory of quantum gravity
they change their perspective altogether
we are not describing the hydronic
physics we are describing this theory of
quantum gravity and that's when string
theory probably got
like exciting that this could be the
unifying theory
exactly it got exciting but at the same
time not so fast
namely it should have been fast but it
wasn't
because particle physics through quantum
filter was so successful
at that time this is mid 70s standard
model of physics electromagnetism and
unification of electromagnetic forces
with all the other forces
were beginning to take place without the
gravity part
everything was working beautifully for
particle physics
and so that was the shining golden age
of quantum field theory and all the
experiments standard model this and that
unification and spontaneous symmetry
breaking was taking place all of them
was nice
this was kind of like a sideshow and
nobody was paying so much attention
this exotic string is needed for quantum
gravity ah maybe there's other ways
maybe we should do something else
so yeah it wasn't paid much attention to
and
this took a little bit more effort to
try to actually connect it to
to the reality there are a few more
steps first of all
there was a puzzle that you were getting
extra dimensions
string was not working well with three
spatial dimensions on one time
it needed extra dimension now
there are different versions of strings
but the version that ended up being
related
to having particles like electron what
we call fermions
needed 10 dimensions what we call super
string
now why super white the word super it
turns out this
uh this version of the string which had
fermions
had an extra symmetry which we call
supersymmetry
this is a symmetry between a particle
and another particle with exactly the
same properties same mass
same charge etc the only difference is
that one of them has a little different
spin
than the other one and one and one of
them is the boson
one of them is a fermion because of that
shift of spin
otherwise they're identical so there was
this symmetry string theory
had the symmetry in fact supersymmetry
was discovered
through string theory theoretically
so theoretically the first place that
this was observed when when you were
describing these
fermionic strings so that was the
beginning of the study of supersymmetry
was the via string theory
and then it had remarkable properties
that you know this symmetry
meant and so forth that people began
studying supersymmetry after that
and that was continuation that was kind
of a tangent direction at the beginning
for string theory but people in particle
physics started also thinking oh
supersymmetry is great let's see if we
can have
supersymmetry in particle physics and so
forth forget about strings and they
developed on a different track as well
supersymmetry in different models became
a subject on its own right
understanding supersymmetry and what
does this mean
because it unified bosons and fermi and
unifies some ideas together
so photon is a boson electron is a
fermion
could things like that be somehow
related it was a kind of a natural kind
of a question to try to kind of unify
because
in physics we love unification now
gradually string theory was beginning to
show signs of unification it had
graviton
but people found that you also have
things like photons in them
different excitations of string behave
like photons another one behaves like
electron
so a single string was unifying all
these particles into one object
that's remarkable it's in ten dimensions
though
it is not our universe because we live
in three plus one dimension how could
that be possibly true
so this was a conundrum it was elegant
it was beautiful but it was very
specific
about which dimension you're getting
which structure you're getting
it wasn't saying oh you just put d
equals to four you'll get your space
time dimension that you want no
it didn't like that it said i want ten
dimensions and that's the way it is
so it was very specific now so people
try to reconcile this by the idea that
you know
maybe these extra dimensions are tiny so
if you take
three macroscopic spatial dimensions on
one time
and six extra tiny spatial dimensions
like tiny spheres or tiny circles then
it avoids contradiction with manifest
fact that we haven't seen extra
dimensions in
experiments today so that was a way to
avoid
conflict now this was a way to avoid
conflict
but it was not observed in experiments
a string observed in experiments no
because it's so small
so it's beginning to sound a little bit
funny
similar feeling to the way perhaps drag
had felt about this positron plus or
minus you know it was beginning to sound
a little bit like
oh yeah not only i have to have ten
dimension but i also have to this i have
to also listen
and so you so conservative physicists
would say um
you know i haven't seen these
experiments i don't know if they are
really there are you pulling my leg
i do you want me to imagine things that
are not there so this was an attitude of
some physicist
towards string theory despite the fact
that the puzzle of gravity and quantum
mechanics merging together work
but still was this skepticism you're
putting all these things that you want
me to imagine there are these extra
dimensions that i cannot see uh-huh
and you want me to believe that stream
that you have not even seen experiments
are real uh-huh okay what else do you
want me to believe
so it was kind of beginning to sound a
little funny now
i was i would pass forward forward a
little bit further
um a few decades later when string3
became the mainstream
of efforts to unify the forces and
particles together
we learned that these extra dimensions
actually solved problems
they weren't in nuisance the way they
originally appeared
first of all the properties of these
extra dimensions
reflected the number of particles we got
in four dimensions
if you took these six dimensions to have
like six five holes or four holes that
tend to
change the number of particles that you
see in four dimensional space time
you get one electron and one muon if you
had this but if you did the other j
shape you get something else so
geometrically you could get different
kinds of physics so it was kind of in
a mirroring of geometry by physics down
in the macroscopic space so these extra
dimensions
were becoming useful fine but we didn't
need the extra dimensions to just write
an electron in three dimensions we did
we wrote it so
so what was there any other puzzle yes
there were
hawking hawking had been studying black
holes in mid 70s
following the work of wickenstein who
had predicted
that black holes have entropy
so wickenstein had tried to attach the
entropy to the black hole
if you throw something into that black
hole the entropy seems to go down
because you have something entropy in
outside the black hole and you throw it
entropy was you it black was unique so
the entropy did not have any
blackout no entropy so you seem the
entropy seem to go down and so that's
against the laws of thermodynamics so
beckenstein was trying to say no no
therefore black must have an entropy so
he was trying to understand that he
found that if you assign
entropy to the to be proportional to the
area of the black hole it seems to work
and then hawking
found not only that's correct he found
the correct proportionality factor of
factor of one quarter of the area and
planck units is the
correct amount of entropy and he gave an
argument using
quantum semi-classical arguments which
barely which means basically using a
little bit of a quantum mechanics
because he didn't have the full quantum
mechanics of string there he could do
some aspects of approximate quantum
arguments
so heuristic quantum arguments led to
this entropy form
formula but then he didn't answer the
following question
he was getting a big entropy for the
black hole the black hole with the size
of the horizon of a black hole is huge
has a huge amount of entropy
what are the microstates of this entropy
when you say for example the gaseous
entropy
you count where the atoms are you count
this this bucket or that but there's an
information about there and so on you
count them
for the black hole the way hawking was
thinking there was no degree of freedom
you throw them in
and there was just one solution so where
are these
entropy what are what are these
microscopic states
they were hidden somewhere so later in
string theory
uh the work that we did with my
colleague strong manager
in particular showed that these
ingredients in string theory
of black hole arise from the extra
dimensions
so the degrees of freedom are are hidden
in terms of things like strings
wrapping these extra circles in these
hidden dimensions
and then we started counting how many
ways like the strings can wrap around
this circle and the
extra dimension or that circle and
counted the microscopic degrees of
freedom
and lo and behold we got the microscopic
degrees of freedom that
hawking was predicting four dimensions
so the extra dimensions became useful
for resolving a puzzle in four
dimensions the puzzle was
where are the degrees of freedom of the
black hole hidden the answer
hidden in the extra dimensions the tiny
extra dimensions
so then by this time it was beginning to
we see aspects
that extra dimensions are useful for
many things it's not a nuisance
it wasn't to be kind of you know be
ashamed of it was actually in the
welcome features
new feature nevertheless how do you
intuit
the 10-dimensional world so yes it's a
feature for describing certain phenomena
like the the entropy in black holes
but what you said that to you a theory
becomes
real or becomes powerful when you can
connect it to some
deep intuition so how do we intuit yes
ten dimensions
yes um so i will i will explain uh how
some of the analogies work first of all
we do a lot of analogies
and by analogies we build intuition so i
will i will start with this example
i will try to explain that if we are in
10 dimensional space
if we have a seven dimensional plane and
eight dimensional plane
we ask typically in what space do they
intersect each other in what dimension
that might sound like how do you
possibly give an answer to this
so we start with lower dimensions we
start with two dimensions we say if you
have one dimension
and a point do they intersect typically
on a plane the answer is no
so a line one dimensional a point zero
dimension
on a two dimensional plane they don't
typically meet but if you have a
one-dimensional line and another
line which is one plus one on a plane
they typically intersect
at a point typically means if you're not
parallel typically they intersect at a
point
so one plus one is two and in two
dimension
they intersect at the zero dimensional
point so you see two dimension
one and one two two minus two is zero so
you get point
out of intersection okay let's go to
three dimension
you have a plane two dimensional plane
and a point do they intersect no two and
zero
how about a plane and a line a plane is
two dimensional and a line is one two
plus one is three
in three dimension a plane and a line
meet at points
which is zero dimensionals three minus
three is zero okay
so plane and the line intersect at the
point in three dimensions how about the
plane on a plane in three d
well plane is two and this is two two
plus two is four
in three d four minus three is one they
intersect on a one dimensional line
okay we're beginning to see the pattern
okay now come to the question we're in
ten dimensions now we have the intuition
we have a seven dimensional plane and
eight dimensional plane in ten dimension
they intersect on a plane what's the
dimension well seven plus eight is 15
minus 10 is 5.
we draw the same picture as two planes
and we write seven dimension eight
dimension but we have gotten the
intuition from the lower dimensional one
what to expect it doesn't scare us
anymore
so we draw this picture we cannot see
all the seven dimensions by looking at
this
two-dimensional visualization of it but
it has all the features we want
it has so i we draw this picture which
is seven seven and they they meet at the
five-dimensional plane
it says five so we have we have build
this intuition now
this is an example of how we come up
with intuition
let me give you more examples of it
because i think this will show you that
people have to come up with intuitions
to visualize that otherwise we
will be a little bit uh lost so what you
just
described is kind of uh in these high
dimensional spaces focus on the meeting
place of uh two planes in high
dimensional spaces
exactly how the planes meet for example
what's the dimension of their
intersection and so on so how do we come
up with the intuition we
borrow examples from door dimensions
build up intuition and
draw the same pictures as if we are
talking about
10 dimensions but we are drawing the
same as the two dimensional plane
because we cannot do any better
but our our our words change
but not our pictures so your senses we
can have a deep understanding
of reality by looking at its at slices
a lower dimensional slice exactly
exactly and this this is that comes
brings me to the next example i want to
mention
which is sphere let's think about how do
we think about the sphere
well the sphere is a sphere you know the
round nice thing but
sphere has a circular symmetry now
i can describe the sphere in the
following way i can describe it
by an interval which is
think about this going from the north of
the sphere to the south
and at each point i have a circle
attached to it
so you can think about the sphere as a
line with a circle attached with
each point the circle shrinks to a
circle string to a point
at endpoints of the interval so i can
say oh one way to think about the sphere
is an interval where at each point on
that interval there's another circle i'm
not drawing
but if you like you can just draw it say
okay i won't draw it so from now on
is this mnemonic i draw an interval when
i want to talk about the sphere and you
remember
that the end points of the interval mean
a strong circle that's all
and they say yeah i see that's a sphere
good now we want to talk about the
product of two spheres
that's four dimensional how can i
visualize it easy
you just take an interval and it's
another interval that's just going to be
a square
yeah a square is a four dimensional
space yeah why is that well at each
point
on the square there's two circles one
for each of those directions you drew
and when you get to the boundaries of
each direction one of the circles shrink
on each edge of that square
and when you get to the corners of the
square all both circles shrink
this is a sphere times a sphere i have
divine interval
i just described for you a
four-dimensional space do you want the
six-dimensional space no problem
take the take a corner of a room in fact
if you want to have a sphere times a
stick take sphere times the sphere times
the sphere
take a cube a cube
is a rendition of this six dimensional
space this two
sphere times another sphere times on the
sphere where three of the circles i'm
not drawing for you
for each one of those directions there's
another circle but each time you get to
the boundary of the cube one
circle shrinks when the boundaries meet
two circuit strings when three
boundaries meet
all the three circles shrink so i just
give you a picture now
mathematicians come up with amazing
things like you know what i want to take
a point in space and blow it up
you know these concepts like topology
and geometry complicated how do you do
in this picture it's very easy blow it
up in this picture means the following
you think about this cube you go to the
corner and you chop off a corner
chopping off the corner replaces the
point yeah you raise the point by
triangle
yes that's called blowing up a point and
then this triangle is what they call p2
projective two space
but these pictures are very physical and
you feel it there's nothing amazing i'm
not talking about six dimension
four plus six is ten the dimension of
string theory so we can visualize that
no problem
okay so that's building the intuition to
a complicated world
of string theory nevertheless these
objects are really small
and just like you said experimental
validation is very difficult because the
objects
are way smaller than anything that we
currently have the tools and
accelerators and so on to uh
to reveal through experiment so
there's a kind of skepticism that's not
just about
the nature of the theory because of the
10 dimensions as you've explained
but in that we can't experimentally
validate it
and it doesn't necessarily to date maybe
can correct me
predicts something fundamentally new
so it's it's beautiful as an explaining
theory
which means that it's very possible that
it is a fundamental theory that
describes reality and unifies the laws
but there's still a kind of skepticism
and uh me from a sort of an outside
observer perspective have been observing
a little bit of a
growing cynicism about string theory in
the recent few years
can you describe the cynicism about sort
of
by cynicism i mean a cynicism about
the hope for this theory of
pushing theoretical physics forward yes
can you do describe why this is cynicism
and how do we reverse that trend yes
first of all
the criticism uh for string theory
uh is healthy in some in a sense that in
science we
we have to have different viewpoints and
that's good so i don't i welcome
criticism
uh and the the the reason for criticism
and i think that is a valid reason is
that there has been zero experimental
evidence for string theory
that is no experiment has been done
to show that there's you know there's
this little loop of energy moving around
and so that's a valid valid uh objection
and valid worry
and if i were to say you know what
string theory can never be verified or
experimentally checked that's the way it
is
they would have every right to say what
you're talking about is not science
because in science we will have to have
experimental consequences and checks
the difference between string theory and
something which is not scientific is
that string 3 has predictions
the problem is that the predictions we
have today of string theory is hard to
access by experiments available with the
energies we can
achieve with the colliders today it
doesn't mean there's a problem with
string theory it just means
technologically we're not that far ahead
now
we can have two attitudes you say well
if that's the case why are you studying
this subject because you can't do
experiment today
now this is becoming a little bit more
like mathematics in that sense you say
well
i want to learn i want to know how the
nature works even though i cannot prove
it today
that this is it because of experiments
that should not prevent my mind not to
think about it that's right
so that's the attitude many string tears
follow that that that
should be like this now so that's that's
the answer to the criticism but there's
actually a better answer to the
criticism i would say
we don't have experimental evidence for
string theory but we have theoretical
evidence for string theory and what do i
mean by
theoretical evidence for string theory
string theory has connected
different parts of physics together
it didn't have to it has brought
connections between part of physics
although
suppose you're just interested in
particle physics suppose you're not even
interested in gravity at all
it turns out there are partic properties
of certain particle physics models
that string theory has been able to
solve using gravity
using ideas from string theory ideas
known as holography
which is relating something which has to
do with particles to something having to
do with gravity
why did it have to be this rich this
subject is
very rich it's not something we were
smart enough to develop
it came at us as i explained to you the
development of string theory came from
accidental discovery it wasn't because
we were smart enough to come up with
idea oh yeah string of course has
gravity no it was accident discovery so
some people say it's not fair to say we
have no
evidence for string theory graviton
gravity is that evidence for string
theory
it's predicted by string theory we
didn't put it by hand we got it
so there's a qualitative check okay
gravity
is a prediction of string theory it's a
postdiction because we know gravity
existed
but still logically it is a prediction
because
really we didn't know it had that
graviton that we later learned that oh
that's the same as gravity so literally
that's the way it was discovered it
wasn't put in by hand
so so there are there are many things
like that that there are there are
different facets of physics
like questions in condensed matter
physics questions of particle physics
questions about this and that has have
come together to find beautiful
answers by using ideas from string
theory
at the same time as a lot of new math
has emerged that's an aspect which i
wouldn't emphasize
as evidence to physicists necessarily
because they will say okay great you got
some math but what's to do with reality
but as i explained many of the physical
principles we know of
have beautiful math underpinning them so
it certainly leads further
confidence that we may not be going
astray even though that's not the food
proof as we know
so so there are these aspects that give
further evidence
for string theory connections between
each other connection with the real
world but then there are other things
that come about
and i can try to give examples of that
so
so these are further evidences and these
are certain predictions of string theory
they are not as as as detailed as we
want but there are still predictions
why is the dimension of space on time
three plus one
see i don't know just just deal with it
three plus one
but in physics we want to know why
well take a random dimension from one to
infinity what's your random
dimension a random dimension from one to
infinity would not be four
eight would most likely be a humongous
number if not infinity i mean
there's no if you choose any any
reasonable distribution which goes from
one to infinity
three or four would not be your pick the
fact that we are in three or four
dimension is already strange
the fact that string says sorry i cannot
go beyond 10 or maybe 11 or something
the fact that they're just upper bound
the range is not from 1 to infinities
from 1 to 10 or 11 or what not
it already brings a natural prior oh
yeah three or four is you know it's just
on the average if you
if you pick some of the
compactifications then it could easily
be that so in other words
it makes it much more possible that it
could be theory of our universe so
the fact that the dimension already is
so small it
should be surprising we don't ask that
question we should be surprised
because we could have conceived of
universes with our predimension
why is it that we have such a small
dimension that's number one
so oh so so good theory of the universe
should give you an intuition of
the why it's four or three plus one
and it's not obvious that it should be
that that should be explained we take
that as a
as an assumption but that's a thing that
should be explained
yeah so we haven't explained that in
string here actually i did write a model
within string theory to try to describe
why we end up with three
uh plus one space time dimensions which
are big compared to the rest of them
and even though this has not been uh the
technical difficulties to prove it
is is still not there but i will explain
the idea
because the idea connects to some other
piece of elegant math
which is the following consider a a
universe
made of a box three-dimensional box or
in fact
if we start in string theory
nine-dimensional box because we have
nine spatial dimensions at one time
so imagine a nine-dimensional box
so we should imagine the box of the
typical size of the string which
is small so the universe would naturally
small
start with a very tiny nine dimensional
box
what do strings do well strings go you
know go around the box and move around
and vibrate and all that but also
they can wrap around one side of the box
to the other because
i'm imagining a box with periodic
boundary conditions so what we call the
torus
so the string can go from one side to
the other this is what we call a winding
string the string can wind around the
box
suppose you have you now evolve the
universe
because there's energy the universe
starts to expand
but it doesn't it doesn't expand too far
why is it
well because there are these strings
which are wrapped around from one side
of the wall to the other
when the universe the walls of the
universe are growing
it is stretching the string and the
strings are becoming very very massive
so it becomes difficult to expand it
kind of puts a halt on it in order to
not with a halt a string which is going
this way and a thing which is going that
way should
should uh intersect each other and
disconnect each other and unwind
so a string which is winds this way and
the string which finds the opposite way
should find each other to to to
reconnect
and this way disappear so if they find
each other and they did these
they disappear but how can strings find
each other well the string moves
and another string moves a string is one
dimensional one plus one is two
and one plus one is two and two plus two
is four
in four dimensional space time they will
find each other
in a higher dimensional space time they
typically miss each other
oh interesting so if the dimensions were
too big they would miss each other they
wouldn't be able to expand
so in order to expand they have to find
each other and three of them can't find
each other and those can expand and the
other one will be stuck so that explains
why within string theory these
particular dimensions are really big
and full of exciting stuff that could be
an explanation that's the model we we
we suggested with my colleague
brandenburger but it turns out to be
related to a deep piece of math
you see for mathematicians
manifolds of dimension bigger than four
are simple
four dimension is the hardest dimension
for math
it turns out and it turns out the reason
it's difficult is the following it turns
out that in
higher dimension you use you use
what's called surgery in mathematical
terminology where you use these two
dimensional tubes
to maneuver them off of each other so
you have two plus two
becoming four and higher than four
dimension you can pass them through each
other
without them intersecting in fourth
dimension
two plus two doesn't allow you to pass
them through each other so the same take
things that work in higher dimension
don't work in four dimension
because two plus two is four the same
reasoning i was just telling you
about strings finding each other and
four ends up to be the reason why four
is much more complicated
to classify for mathematicians as well
so so there might be these
these things so i cannot say that this
is the reason that string theory is
is giving you three plus one but it
could be a model for it and so
so there are these kind of ideas that
could underlie why
we have three extra dimensions which are
large and the rest of our small but
absolutely we have to have a good reason
we cannot leave it like that can i ask a
tricky human question
so you are one of the seminal figures
in string theory you got the
breakthrough prize you worked with
edward whitten
there is no nobel prize that has been
given on string theory
you know credit assignment is tricky in
science i've
it makes you quite sad especially big
like ligo big experimental projects when
so many
incredible people have been involved and
yet the nobel prize
is annoying in that it's only given to
three people who do you think
gets the nobel prize for string theory
uh
at first if it turns out that it
um if not in full then in part
is is a good model of
the way the physics of the universe
works
who are the key figures maybe let's put
nobel prize aside
or the key figures i like the second
version of the question because i think
to try to give a prize to one person in
string there doesn't do justice to the
diversity of the subject that to me is
so there was quite a lot of incredible
people there in the history of quite a
lot of people i mean starting with
vanessa who wasn't talking about strings
yes i mean he wrote down the the
beginning of a string so we cannot
ignore that for sure and so
so you start with that and you go on
with various other figures and so on so
there are different epochs in string
theory
yes and different people have been
pushing it and so for example the early
epoch we just told you people like uh
like veneziano
and nambu and the saskan and others were
pushing it green and shorts were pushing
it and so forth
so this was or shark and so on so these
were the initial periods of
pioneers i would say of string theory
and then there were there were the
mid 80s that uh edward whitten was the
major proponent of string theory and he
really
changed the landscape of string theory
in terms of what people do and how
how we view it and i think his efforts
brought a lot of attention to the
community about
a high energy community to focus on this
effort as the correct theory of
unification of forces so he brought a
lot of research as well as of course the
first rate work he himself did
to this area so that's in 80s and
onwards and also in mid 90s where he
was one of the proponents of the duality
revolution in string theory
and with that came a lot of these other
ideas that you know
led to breakthroughs involving for
example
the example i told you about black holes
and holography and the work that was
later done by maldasena about the
properties of duality between particle
physics and
quantum gravity and the connections the
deeper connections of holography
and it continues and there are many
people within this range which i haven't
even mentioned
they have done fantastic important
things
how it gets recognized i think is
secondary in my opinion
than the appreciation that the effort is
collective
that in fact that to me is the more
important part of science that gets
forgotten
for some reason humanity likes heroes
and science is no exception we like
heroes
but i i personally try to avoid that
trap
i i feel and in my work most of my work
is with colleagues
i have much more collaborations than
soul author papers
and i enjoy it and i think that that's
to me one of the most satisfying aspects
of science
is to interact and learn and
debate ideas with colleagues because
that influx of ideas enriches it
and that's why i i find it interesting
to me science if i was in an island and
if i was developing strength here by
myself and had nothing to do with
anybody it would be much less satisfying
in my opinion
even if i could take credit i did it
yeah
it won't be as satisfying sitting alone
with the yeah with a big metal
drinking champagne no i think i think to
me the collective work is more exciting
and
you mentioned my getting the
breakthrough when i was getting it i
made sure to mention that it is because
of the joint work that i've done with
colleagues at that time it was around
180 or so collaborators and i
acknowledge them
in the in the web page for them i write
all of their names and the
collaborations that led to this so
to me science is fun when it's
collaboration
and yes there are more important and
less important figures as in any field
and that's true that's true in strength
here as well but i think that
i would like to view this as a
collective effort so
setting the heroes aside the nobel prize
is a celebration of um what's the right
way to put it
that this idea turned out to be right
so like you look at uh einstein didn't
believe in black holes
right and then black holes got their
nobel prize
right do you think string theory will
get
its nobel prize nobel prizes
if you were to bet money if this was
like if this was an investment meeting
and we had to bet
all our money do you think he gets the
nobel prizes
i think it's possible that none of the
living physicists will get the nobel
prize on string theory but somebody will
because because unfortunately the
technology available today is not very
encouraging
in terms of seeing directly evidence for
string theory do you think this
ultimately boils down
to the nobel prize will be given when
there is some
direct or indirect evidence there would
be but
uh but i think that part of this
breakthrough prize was precisely the
appreciation that when we have
sufficient evidence
theoretical as it is and not experiment
because of this
technology lag you appreciate what what
you think is the correct path
so there are many people who have been
have been recognized precisely
because they may not be around when it
actually gets experimented
even though they discovered it so so
there are there are many things like
that that's going on in
in science so i think that i would i
would want to attach
less significance to the recognitions
of people and i i have i have a i have a
second review on this which is
there are people who you know who look
at these works that people have done
and put them together and you know make
the next big breakthrough
and they get identified with you know
perhaps rightly with
many of these you know new new visions
but they are on the shoulders of these
little scientists yes
which don't get any recognition you know
yeah you did this little work oh yeah
you did this little
work oh yeah yeah five of you oh yeah
this showed this pattern and then
somebody else
it's not fair yeah to me to me those
little guys
which which kind of like like seem to do
a little calculation here a little thing
there which is not doesn't
doesn't rise to the occasion of this
grandiose kind of thing doesn't make it
to the new york times
headlines and so on deserve a lot of
recognition and i think they don't get
enough i would say that
there should be this nobel prize for you
know they have these
doctors without borders a huge group
they should do similar thing
these string theories without borders
kind of everybody is doing a lot of work
and i think that
i i would like to see that efforts
recognized i think
in the long arc of history we're all
little guys and girls standing on the
shoulders of each other i mean
it's all going to look tiny in
retrospective we celebrate
the new york times uh
it you know as a newspaper or the idea
of a newspaper
in a few centuries from now will be long
forgotten yes
especially in the countries of string
theory we should have a very long term
view yes exactly
just as a tiny tangent we mentioned
edward wooden
and he in a bunch of walks of life for
me as an outsider comes up as a person
who is uh widely considered as like
one of the most brilliant people in the
history of physics just as a powerhouse
uh of a human like the uh
the exceptional places that a human mind
can rise to
yes uh you've gotten a chance to work
with him what's he like yes
more than that he was my advisor a phd
advisor so i got to know him very well
and i benefited from his insights in
fact
what you said about him is accurate he
is he's not only brilliant but you know
he is
he's also multifaceted in terms of the
impact he has had in not only physics
but also mathematics
you know he's got in the fields medal
because of his work in mathematics and
rightly so you know he has used his
knowledge of physics in a way which
impacted
deep ideas in modern mathematics and
that's an example of
of the power of of these ideas in modern
high energy physics and string theory
that
the applicability of it to to modern
mathematics
so he's uh he's quite uh
exceptional individual we don't we don't
come across such people a lot in history
so i think yes indeed he's one of the
rare figures in this history of
of the subject he has had great impact
on a lot of aspects of not just string
theory a lot of different areas in
physics
and also yes in mathematics as well so i
think what you said about him is
accurate
i had the pleasure of interacting with
him as a student and and later on as
colleagues
writing papers together and so on what
impact do you have on your life like
what have you learned from him if you
were to look at the trajectory of your
mind of the way you approached science
and physics and mathematics
how did he uh perturb that trajectory
yes
he did actually so i can explain because
when i was a student i
i i the biggest impact by him uh clearly
as a grad student at princeton so i
think
that was the time where i was a little
bit confused
about the relation between math and
physics i got a double major in
mathematics and physics at mit
and because i really enjoyed both and i
write the elegance and the
rigor of mathematics and i like the
power of ideas and physics and its
applicability to reality and what it
teaches about
the real world around us but i saw this
tension between
rigorous thinking in mathematics and
lack thereof in physics and this
troubled me to no end i was troubled by
that
so i was at crossroads when i decided to
go to graduate school in physics
because i did not like some of the lack
of rigors i was seeing in physics
on the other hand to me mathematics even
though it was rigorous something it it
sometimes were i didn't see the point of
it in other words
when i see when i see you know the math
theorem by itself could be beautiful but
i really wanted more than that i want to
say okay what did it teach us about
something else something more than just
math
so i wasn't i wasn't that enamored with
just math but physics was a little bit
bothersome nevertheless i decided to go
to physics and i decided to go to
princeton
and i started working with edward
whitten as my thesis advisor
and um at that time i was trying to
put physics in rigorous mathematical
terms i took quantum fifth theory
i tried to make rigorous out of it and
so on
and no matter how hard i was trying i
was not
being able to do that and i was falling
behind from my classes i was not
learning
much physics and i was not making it
rigorous and to me
it was this dichotomy between math and
physics what am i doing i like math but
this is not
exactly risk there comes ed written as
my advisor and i see him in action
thinking about math and physics
he was amazing in math he knew all about
the math it was no problem with him
but he thought about physics in a way
which did not
find this tension between the two
it was much more harmonious for him he
would draw the feynman diagrams but he
wouldn't
view it as a formalism he was viewed oh
yeah the particle goes over there and
this is what's going on and
so wait you're thinking really is this
particle this virtual this is really
electron going there right
yeah it's not it's not the formula
perturbation no no
you just feel like the electron you're
moving with this guy and do that and so
on and you're thinking invariantly about
physics or the way he thought about
relativity like you know i was thinking
about you know this momentum says he was
thinking invariantly about physics just
like the way
you think about invariant concepts in
relativity which don't depend on the
frame of reference
he was thinking about the physics in in
variant ways that
the way that doesn't gives you a bigger
perspective so
this gradually helped me appreciate that
interconnections between ideas and
physics replaces
mathematical rigor that the different
facets
reinforce each other you say oh i cannot
rigorously define what i mean by this
but this thing connects with this other
physics i have seen and this other thing
and they together form an elegant story
and that replaced for me what i believed
as a solidness which i found in math as
a rigor
and was solid i found that replaced the
rigor and solidness in physics
so i found okay that's the way you can
hang on to
it is not wishy-washy it's not like
somebody is just not being able to prove
it just making up a story
it was more than that and it was no
tension with mathematics
in fact mathematics was helping it like
friends
and so much more harmonious and gives
insights to physics so that's i think
one of the main things i learned from
interactions with written
and i think that now perhaps i have
taken
that to a far extreme maybe he wouldn't
go this far as i have namely
i use physics to define new mathematics
in a way which would be far
less rigorous than a physicist might
necessarily believe because i take the
physical intuition
perhaps literally in many ways that
could teach us the man so now i've
gained so much confidence in physical
intuition that i make bold statements
that sometimes you know
takes math math friends off guard
so an example of it is mirror symmetry
so
so we were studying these compactivation
of string string geometries this is
after my phd now i've
by the time i've come to harvard we're
studying these aspects of string compact
education on these
complicated manifolds six dimensional
spaces called calabial manifolds
very complicated and i noticed
with a couple other colleagues that
there was a symmetry
in physics suggested between different
calabias it suggested that
you couldn't actually compute the euler
characteristic of a calabria or the
characteristic is
counting the number of points minus the
number of edges plus the number of faces
minus
so you can count the alternating
sequence of properties of the space
which is the topological
property of a space so holy cat axis of
the calabia was a property of the space
and so
we noticed that from the physics
formalism if string moves in a calabia
you cannot distinguish we cannot compute
the euler characteristic you can only
compute the absolute value of it
now this bothered us because how could
it do not compute the actual sign
unless the both sides were the same
so i conjectured maybe for every calabia
with the other character is positive
there's one with negative
i told this to my colleague yao who was
whose namesake is calabia um
that i'm making this conjecture is it
possible that for every calabia there's
one with the opposite euler
characteristic
sounds not reasonable i said why he said
well we know more
claudia's with negative other characters
than positive
i said but physics says we cannot
distinguish them at least i don't see
how
so we conjectured that for every calabia
with one side there's the other one
despite the mathematical evidence
despite the mathematical evidence
despite the expert
telling us is not the right idea if a
few years later this symmetric mirror
symmetry between the
sign with the opposite sign was later
confirmed by mathematicians
so this is actually the opposite view
that is physics is so sure about it
that you're going against the
mathematical wisdom telling them they
better look for it
so taking the uh the the physical
intuition literally
and then having that drive the the
mathematics exactly and by now we are so
confident about
many such examples that has affected
modern mathematics
in ways like this that we are much more
confident about our
understanding of what string theories
these are another aspects other aspects
of why
we feel string terrorists cry it's doing
these kind of things
i've been hearing you talk quite a bit
about uh string
theory landscape and the swamp what the
heck are those two concepts
okay very good question so let's go back
to what i was describing about feinman
yes feinman was trying to do these
diagrams for graviton
and electrons and all that he found that
he's getting infinities he cannot
resolve
okay the natural conclusion is that
field theories and gravity and quantum
theory don't go together
and you cannot have it so in other words
field theories
and gravity are inconsistent with
quantum mechanics period
string theory came up with
examples but didn't address the question
more broadly that
is it true that every field theory can
be coupled to gravity in a quantum
mechanical way
it turns out that final is essentially
right
almost all particle physics theories no
matter what you add to it
when you put gravity in it doesn't work
only
rare exceptions work so string theory
are those rare exceptions
so therefore the general principle that
feynman found was correct
quantum field theory and gravity and
quantum mechanics don't go together
except for jules exceptional cases there
are exceptional cases
okay the the total vastness of quantum
field theories that are there
we called the set of quantum field
theories
possible things which ones can be
consistently coupled to gravity
we call that subspace the landscape
the rest of them we call the swampland
it doesn't mean they are bad quantum
field theories they are perfectly fine
but when you couple them to gravity they
don't make sense unfortunately
and it turns out that the the ratio of
them then the number of theories which
are consistent with gravity the to the
ones which without
the ratio of the area of the landscape
to the swamp land in other words
is measured zero and so the swamp land
is infinitely large
the swampland's infinitely large so let
me give you one example
take a theory in four dimension with
matter
with maximum amount of supersymmetry can
you get
it turns out a theory in four dimension
with maximum amount of supersymmetry
is characterized just with one thing a
group what we call the gauge group
once you pick a group you have to find
your theory
okay so does every group make sense yeah
as far as quantum field theory every
group makes sense there are infinitely
many groups there are infinitely many
quantum field theories
but it turns out there are only finite
number of them
which are consistent with gravity out of
that same list
so you can take any group but only fine
number of them the ones whose
what we call the rank of the group the
ones whose rank
is less than 23. anyone bigger than rank
23
belongs to the sworn plan they're
infinitely many of them they're
beautiful field theories
but not when you include gravity so
so then this becomes a hopeful thing so
in other words in our universe
we have gravity therefore we are part of
that jewel subset
now is this joule subset small or large
yeah it turns out that subset is
humongous but we believe still finite
the setup possibility is infinite but
the set of
consistent ones i mean the set of
quantum features are infinite
but the consistent ones are finite but
humongous
the fact that they're humongous is the
problem we are facing in string theory
because we do not know
which one of these possibilities the
universe we live in
if we knew we could make more specific
predictions about our universe we don't
know
and that is one of the challenges with
string theory which point on the
landscape which corner of this landscape
do we live in we don't know so what do
we do
well there are there are principles that
are beginning to emerge
so i will give you one example of it you
look at the patterns of what you're
getting
in terms of these good ones the ones
which are in the landscape compared to
the ones which are not
you find certain patterns i'll give you
one pattern
you find in the all the ones that you
get from string theory
gravitational force is always there but
it's always
always the weakest force
however you could easily imagine field
theories
for which gravity is not the weakest
force for example
take our universe if you take mass of
the electron if you increase the mass of
electron by huge factor
the gravitational attraction of the
electrons will be bigger than the
electric repulsion between two electrons
and the gravity will be stronger that's
all
it happens that's not the case in our
universe because electron is
very tiny in mass compared to that just
like our universe
gravity is the weakest force we find in
all these other ones which are part of
the good ones
the gravity is the weakest force this is
called the weak gravity conjecture we
conjectured that
all the points in the landscape have
this property
our universe being just an example of it
so there are these qualitative features
that we are beginning to see
but how do we argue for this just by
looking patterns just by looking string
theory has this
no that's not enough we need more
more reason more better reasoning and it
turns out there is the reasoning for
this turns out to be studying black
holes
ideas of black holes turn out to put
certain restrictions
of what a good quantum filter should be
it turns out
using black hole the fact that the black
holes evaporate
the fact that the black holes evaporate
gives you a way
to to check the relation between the
mass and the charge of elementary
particle because what you can do
you can take a charged particle and
throw it into a charged black hole
and wait it to evaporate and by the
looking at the properties of evaporation
you find that
if it cannot evaporate particles whose
mass is less than their charge
then it will never evaporate you'll be
stuck and so the possibility of a black
hole evaporation forces you to have
particles
whose mass is sufficiently small so that
the gravity is weaker
so you connect this fact to the other
fact so we begin to find
different facts that reinforce each
other so different
parts of the physics reinforce each
other and once they all
kind of come together you believe that
you're getting the principle correct so
weak gravity conjecture is one of the
principles we believe in
has a necessity of these conditions so
these are the predictions string they
are making
is that enough well it's qualitative
it's a
semi-quantity it's just that mass of the
electron should be less than some number
but that number is if i call that number
one
the mass of the electron turns out to be
10 to the minus 20 actually so it's much
less than one it's not
one but on the other hand there's
a similar reasoning for a big black hole
in our universe
and if that evaporation should take
place gives you another restriction
tells you the mass of the electron
is bigger than 10 to the is now in this
case bigger than something
it shows bigger than 10 to the minus 30
in the planck unit so
you find uh-huh the mass of the electron
should be less than one but bigger than
ten to the minus thirty
in our universe the mass of the electron
stands to minus twenty
okay now this kind of you could call
postdiction but i would say
it follows from principles that we now
understand from string theory
first principle so we are making
beginning to make
these kinds of predictions which are
very much
connected to aspects of particle physics
that we didn't think
are related to gravity we thought just
take any electron mass you want
what's the problem it has a problem with
gravity and so that conjecture
has also a happy consequence that it
explains that our universe
like why the heck is gravity so weak as
a force
uh and that's not only an accident but
almost a necessity
if these forces are to coexist
effectively
exactly so that's that's that's the
reinforcement of
of of what we know in our universe but
we are finding that
as a general principle so we want to
know what aspects of our universe
universe is forced on us like the weak
gravity conjecture and other aspects do
we
how much of them do we understand can we
have particles lighter than neutrinos or
maybe that's not possible
you see the neutrino mass it turns out
to be related to dark energy
in a mysterious way naively
there's no relation between dark energy
and a mass of a particle
we have found arguments from within the
swampland kind of ideas
why it has to be related and so
so they're beginning to be these
connections between graph consistency of
quantum gravity
and aspects of our universe gradually
being
sharpened but we're still far from a
precise quantitative prediction like
we have to have such and such but that's
the hope that we are going in that
direction
coming up with the theory of everything
that unifies uh general relativity and
quantum field theories um
this is one of the big dreams of human
civilization
us descendants of apes wondering about
how this world works
so a lot of people dream what are your
thoughts about
sort of other out there ideas on
theories of
everything or unifying
theories so there's a quantum loop
gravity
there's also more sort of like a friend
of mine eric weinstein
beginning to propose something called
geometric unity
so these kinds of attempts whether it's
through mathematical physics or through
other avenues
or with stephen wolfram a more
computational view of the universe
again in his case it's these hyper
graphs that are very tiny objects
as well similarly string theory
and trying to grapple with this world
what do you think
is there any of these uh theories that
are compelling to you that are
interesting
that may turn out to be true or at least
may turn out to contain ideas that are
useful
yes i think the latter i would say that
the containing ideas that are true
is my opinion was what these some of
these ideas might be for example quantum
gravity
is to me not a complete theory of
gravity in any sense but they have some
nuggets of truth in them
and typically what i expect happen and i
have seen
examples of this within string theory
aspects which we didn't think are part
of string theory come to be part of it
for example i'll give you one example
string was believed to be 10 dimensional
and then there was this 11 dimensional
super gravity
and nobody know what the egg is that why
are we getting 11 dimensional super
gravity where a string is saying it
should be 10 dimensional 11 was the
maximum dimension you can have a super
gravity
but string was saying sorry we're 10
dimensional
so for for a while we thought that
theory is wrong because how could this
be because string tear is definitely
theory of everything
we later learned that one of the circles
of string theory itself was
tiny that we had not appreciated that
fact and we discovered by doing thought
experiments and string theory that
there's got to be an extra circle
and that circle is connected to an
11-dimensional perspective
and that's what later on god's called m
theory so
so so there are these kind of things
that you know we do not know what
exactly string theory is we're still
learning so we do not have a final
formulation of string theory
it very well could be that different
facets of different ideas come together
like loop quantum gravity or whatnot but
i wouldn't put them on par namely
loop quantum gravity is a scatter of
ideas
about what happens to space when they
get very tiny for example
you replace things by discrete data and
try to quantize it and so on
and you know it sounds like a natural
idea to quantize space
you know if you were naive trying to do
quantum space you might think about
trying to take points and put them
together in some
discrete fashion in some way that is
reminiscent of quantum gravity
string theory is more subtle than that
for example
i would just give you an example and
this is the kind of thing that we didn't
put in by hand we got it out
and so it's more subtle than so what
happens if you squeeze the space to be
smaller and smaller
well you think that after a certain
distance
the notion of distance should break down
you know
when it goes smaller than planck scale
should break down what happens in string
theory we do not know the full answer to
that but we know the following namely if
you take a space
and bring it smaller and smaller if the
box gets smaller than the planck scale
by a factor of 10
it is equivalent by the duality
transformation to a space which is 10
times bigger
so there's a symmetry called a t duality
which takes
l to one over l well l is measured in
plank units
or more precise string units this
inversion
is a very subtle effect and i would not
have been or any physicist would not
have been able to design a theory which
has this property
that when you make the space smaller it
is as if you are making it bigger
that means there is no there is no
experiment you can do to distinguish the
size of the space
this is remarkable for example einstein
would have said of course i can measure
the size of the space what do i do well
i take a flashlight i send the light
around measure how long it takes for the
light to go around the space and bring
back and find the radius or
circumference of the
the universe what's the problem i said
well suppose you do that and you shrink
it and say well they get smaller and
smaller so what i said well
it turns out in string theory there are
two different kinds of photons
one photon measures one over l the other
one measures l
and so this duality reformulates oh fast
and when the space gets smaller it says
oh no you better use the bigger
perspective because the smaller one is
harder to deal with
so you do this one so so these examples
of loop quantum gravity have none of
these features these features that i'm
telling you about we have learned from
string theory
but they nevertheless have some of these
ideas like topological as gravity
aspects
are emphasizing the context of loop
quantum gravity in some form and so
these ideas might be there in some
kernel
in some corners of string there in fact
i wrote a paper about topological string
theory and some connections with
potentially loop quantum gravity which
could be part of that so there are
little
facets of connections i wouldn't say
they're complete but i would say
most probably what will happen to some
of these ideas the good ones at least
they will be absorbed within to strength
theory if they are occurring
let me ask a crazy out there question
can physics
help us understand life so
uh we spoke so confidently
about the laws of physics being able to
explain reality but
and we even said words like theory of
everything
implying that the word everything is
actually describing everything
is it possible that the four
laws we've been talking about are
actually missing
they are accurate in describing what
they're describing but they're missing
the description of a lot of other things
like
emergence of life uh and
emergence of perhaps consciousness so is
there
do you ever think about this kind of
stuff where
we would need to understand extra
physics to try to explain
the emergence of these complex
pockets of interesting weird stuff that
we call
life and consciousness in this big
homogeneous universe that's mostly
boring and nothing is happening
so first of all we don't claim that
string theory is
the theory of everything in the sense
that we know enough what this theory is
we don't know enough about string theory
itself we are learning it so i wouldn't
say okay give me whatever i will tell
you what is how it works no
however i would say by definition by
definition to me physics is checking all
reality
any form of reality i call it physics
that's my definition i mean i may not
know
a lot of it like maybe the origin of
life and so on maybe a piece of that
but i would call that as part of physics
to me reality is what we're after
i don't claim i know everything about
reality i don't claim string theory
necessarily
has the tools right now to describe all
the reality either
but we are learning what it is so i
would say that i would not put a border
to say no you know from this point
onwards it's not my territory somebody
else's
but whether we need new ideas on string
clear to describe other reality
reality features for sure i believe as i
mentioned i don't believe
any things any of the laws we know today
is final so therefore yes we will need
new ideas this is a very tricky thing
for us to understand
and uh be precise about but
just because you understand the physics
doesn't necessarily mean that
you understand the emergence of
chemistry biology
life intelligence consciousness so those
are built it's like you might understand
the way
bricks work yes but to understand what
it
means to have a happy family right you
you don't construct you don't get from
the bricks so directly
you you right in theory you could uh
if you ran the universe over again but
just
understanding the rules of the universe
doesn't necessarily give you
a sense of the weird beautiful things
that emerge
right no so let me let me describe what
you just said
so there are two questions one is
whether or not the techniques are used
and let's say quantum field theory and
so on will describe how the society
works
yes okay that's far distance far for
different scales of questions that we're
asking here
the question is is there a change of is
there a new law which takes over
that cannot be connected to the other
laws that we know
or of more fundamental laws that we know
do you need new laws to describe it
i don't think that's necessarily the
case in many of these phenomena like
chemistry or so on you mentioned
so we do expect you know in principle
chemistry can be described by quantum
mechanics we don't think there's going
to be a magical thing but chemistry is
complicated yeah
indeed there are rules of chemistry that
you know chemists have put down which
has not been explained yet using quantum
mechanics do i believe that they will be
something described by quantum mechanics
yes i do i don't think they are going to
be sitting there
in this just forever but maybe it's too
complicated and maybe you know we
will wait for very powerful quantum
computers or what not to solve those
problems i don't know
but i don't think in that context we
have no principles to be added to fix
those so by i'm perfectly fine
in the intermediate situation to have
rules of thumb or you know principles
that chemists have found which are
working
which are not founded on the basis of
quantum mechanical laws
which does their job similarly as
biologists do not found everything in
terms of chemistry but they think you
know
there's no reason why chemistry cannot
they don't think necessarily they're
doing something amazingly not possible
with chemistry
coming back to your question does
consciousness for example
bring this new ingredient if indeed it
needs a new ingredient i would call that
new ingredient part of physical law
we have to understand it to me that so i
wouldn't put a line to say okay from
this point onwards you cannot it's
disconnected
it's totally disconnected from strength
or whatever we have to do something else
it's not a line what i'm referring to is
can physics
of a few centuries from now that doesn't
understand consciousness
be much bigger than the physics of today
where the the textbook grows it
definitely will i would say i will grow
i would not
i don't know if it grows because of
consciousness being part of it or we
have different view of consciousness
i do not know where the consciousness
will fit i'm not it's going to be hard
for me to
to to to guess i mean i can make random
guesses now which probably most
most likely is wrong but let me just do
just for the sake of discussion
you know i could say you know you know
brain could be their quantum computer
classical computer their arguments
against this being a quantum thing so
it's probably classical and if it's
classical
it could be like what we are doing in
machine learning slightly more fancy and
so on
okay people can go to this argument to
no end and to know whether consciousness
like this or not or life
does it have any meaning or is there is
there a phase transition where you can
say
does electron have a life or not the at
what level does the particle become live
maybe there is no definite definition of
life in that same way that
you know we cannot say electron if you
you know
a good i like this example quite a bit
um you know we distinguish between
liquid and a gas phase like water is
liquid or
or vapor is gas we say they're different
you can distinguish them actually that's
not true
it's not true because we know from
physics that you can
change temperatures and pressure to go
from liquid to the gas without making
any phase transition
so there is no point that you can say
this was a liquid and this was a gas
you can continuously change the
parameters to go from one to the other
so at the end it's very different
looking like you know i know that water
is different from vapor
but you know there's no precise point
this happens
i feel many of these things that we
think like consciousness clearly
that person is not conscious on the
other one is so there's a difference
like
water and vapor but there's no point you
could say that this is conscious there's
no
sharp transition so it could very well
be that what we call
uh heuristically in daily life
consciousness is similar or life is
similar to that
i don't know if it's like that or not
i'm just hypothesizing that's possible
like there's no there's no discrete
phases there's no
phase transition like that yeah yeah but
this you might
there might be you know concepts of
temperature and pressure
that we need to understand uh to
describe what the heck consciousness in
life is
that that we're totally missing yeah i
think that's not
a useless question even those questions
is back to our original discussion of
philosophy i would say consciousness
and free will for example are topics
that
are very much so in the realm of
philosophy currently yes but i don't
think they will always be
i agree with you i agree with you and i
think i am i'm fine with some topics
being part of a different realm than
physics today
because we don't have the right tools
just like biology was i mean before we
had dna and all that genetics and all
that gradually began to
take hold i mean when mandela when
people were beginning
with face experiments with biology and
chemistry and so on they gradually they
came together
so it wasn't like together so yeah i'll
be perfectly understanding of a
situation where we don't have the tools
so do these experiments that you think
has defines the consciousness in
different form and gradually we will
build it and connect it
and yes we might discover new principles
of nature that we didn't know
i don't know but i would say that if
they are they will be deeply connected
with yes we
we have never we have seen in physics we
don't have things in isolation you
cannot
you cannot compartmentalize you know
this is gravity this is electricity this
is that
we have learned they all talk to each
other there's no way to
to make them you know in one corner and
don't talk so same thing with
anything anything which is real so
consciousness is real so therefore
we have to connect it to everything else
so to me once you connect it you cannot
say it's not reality and once this
reality is physics
i call it physics it may not be the
physics i know today for sure it's not
but
but i wouldn't i would i would be
surprised if there's disconnected
realities that you know you cannot
you cannot imagine them as a part of the
same soup so i guess uh
god doesn't have a biology or chemistry
textbook and mostly
or maybe uh he or she reads it for fun
biology and chemistry but when you're
trying to get some work done it'll be
going to the physics textbook
okay uh what advice let's put on your
wise visionary hat what advice do you
have
for young people today you've um are
you've dedicated your
book actually to your kids to your
family
what advice would you give to them what
advice would you give to young people
today thinking about their career
thinking about life
of how to live a successful life how to
live a good life
yes uh yes i have three sons and in fact
to them i have uh i have tried not to
give too much advice
so even though i've tried to kind of not
give advice maybe
indirectly it has been some impact my
oldest one is doing biophysics for
example and the
the second one is doing machine learning
and the third one is doing theoretical
computer science so there are
there are these facets of interest which
are not too far from my area but i have
not tried to
to impact them in in that way but and
they have followed their own interests
and i think
that's the advice i would give to any
young person follow your own interest
and let it that take you wherever it
takes you um
and this i did in my own case that
uh i was planning to study economics and
electrical engineering
when i started at mit and you know i
discovered that
i'm more passionate about math and
physics and at that time i didn't think
math and physics would make a good
career and so i
was kind of hesitant to go in that
direction but i did because i kind of
felt that that's what i'm driven to do
so i didn't i don't regret it i'm i'm
lucky in the sense that you know society
supports people like me who are doing
you know these abstract stuff which
which may or may not be experimentally
verified even let's not apply to the
data technology in our lifetimes i'm
lucky i'm doing that
and i feel that uh if people follow
their interest they will find a niche
that they're good at and
this coincidence of hopefully their
interests and
and abilities are kind of align
at least to some extent to be able to
drive them to something which is
successful
and not to be driven by things like you
know this doesn't make a good career or
this doesn't do that and my parents
expect that or what about this and
i think ultimately you have to live with
yourself and you only have one life and
it's short
very short i can tell you i'm getting
yes i'm getting there so i know it's
short so you really
want not to not to not to do things that
you don't want to do so i think
follow your interest my strongest advice
to young people yeah it's scary
when your interest doesn't directly map
to a career of the past or of today
so you're almost anticipating future
careers that could be created
is scary um but
yeah there's something to that
especially when the interest and the
ability align
you'll pay you'll pave a path that will
find a way to make money
especially in this society in the in in
the capitalistic united states society
it feels like
um ability and passion paves the way
yes at the very least you can sell funny
t-shirts
yes you've mentioned uh life is short
do you think about um your mortality
are you afraid of death uh i don't think
about my mortality
i think that i don't think about my debt
and i don't think about death in general
too much
first of all it's something that i can't
too much about and i think it's
something that
doesn't it doesn't drive my everyday
action
it is natural to expect that it's
somewhat like the
time reversal situation so we believe
that we have this approximate symmetry
in nature time reversal
going forward we die going backwards we
get born yeah so
what was it to get born it wasn't such a
good or bad feeling i have no feeling of
it so
you know who knows what the death will
feel like uh the moment of death or
whatnot so i don't know
it is not known but uh in what form do
we exist before or after
again it's something that it's uh it's
partly philosophical maybe
i like how you draw comfort from
symmetry it does seem that there is
something asymmetric here
breaking of symmetry because there's
there's something
to the uh creative force of the human
spirit
that goes only one way right that
it seems the finiteness of life is the
thing that drives the creativity
and so it does seem that that um at
least
the contemplation of of the finiteness
of life of mortality
is a thing that helps you get your stuff
together yes i think that's true but
actually i have a different perspective
on that a little bit yes
namely uh suppose i told you you have
you're immortal
yes i think your life will be totally
boring after that
because you will not there's i think
part of the reason we have enjoyment in
life is the finiteness of it
yes and so i think mortality
might be a blessing and immortality may
not
so i think that we value things because
we have that finite life
we we appreciate things we want to do
this we want to do that we have
motivation
if i told you no you have infinite life
oh i don't i don't need to do this today
i have another
it's a billion or trillion or infinite
life so why do i do now
there is no motivation a lot of the
things that we do
are driven by that finiteness this
refinedness of these resources so i
think
it's a blessing in disguise i don't
regret it that we have more
finite life and i think
i think that the the process
of uh being part of this thing that you
know the
the reality to me part of what attracts
me to science
is to connect to that immortality kind
of
namely the laws the reality is beyond us
to me i'm i'm i'm resigned to the fact
that not only me
everybody is going to die so this is a
little bit of a consolation none of us
are going to be around
so therefore okay and none of none of
the people before me are around so
therefore yeah okay this is
something everybody goes through so so
taking that minuscule version of
okay how tiny we are and how short time
it is and so on
to connect to the deeper truth beyond us
the reality beyond us
is what sense of quote-unquote
immortality i would get
namely i at least i can hang on to this
little piece of truth
even though i know i know it's not
complete i know it's going to be
imp imperfect i know it's going to
change and it's going to be improved
but having a little bit deeper insight
than than just the naive thing around us
little earth year and little galaxy and
so on
makes me feel a little bit more uh more
pleasure to
to live this life so i think that's the
way i view my my role as a scientist
yeah this the scarcity of this life
helps us appreciate the beauty of the
the immortal the universal truths of
that physics present us and maybe maybe
one day
physics will will have something to say
about
that that beauty in itself
explaining why the heck it's so
beautiful
to appreciate the laws of physics and
yet
um why it's so tragic that we uh
we would die so quickly yes we do so
quickly so that can be a bit longer
that's for sure
it would be very nice maybe physics will
help out well karma and it was uh
an incredible conversation thank you so
much once again for painting a beautiful
picture
of the history of physics and it kind of
presents a hopeful
um view of the future physics so i
really really appreciate that
it's a huge honor that you talked to me
waste all your valuable titles me
i really appreciate it thanks alex it
was a pleasure and i loved talking with
you and this is wonderful set of
discussions i really enjoyed my time
with this discussion thank you thanks
for listening to this conversation with
comrade vapha
and thank you to headspace jordan
harmorger show
squarespace and all form check them out
in the description
to support this podcast and now let me
leave you with some words
from the great richard feynman physics
isn't the most important thing love is
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you